[Music]
it was a little bit special here to have
you guys know how it is man you you guys
are fathers right and uh and all that
kind of thing you know how important it
is so my dad uh
you know tell me what you think about
these guys cause you tell me i want you
to tell them
been around this game a long time been
around a lot of games like you've played
today
when all the adversity that cut could
come to a team came to you today and you
rose up like the champions that you are
[Music]
jack harbaugh with the family chant that
dates back to when john and jim were
little kids and the ravens now feeling
like little kids giddy at 11 and 2 and
the best team in the nfl clearly the
best team in the afc so it's fill in the
blank time chris sims on this tuesday
edition of pft live yeah yeah after the
baltimore ravens the blank are the best
team in the afc whoa man that is a tough
one because there's no clear-cut second
that's your truck i'm gonna go with the
kansas city chiefs i am um i think the
what what i've seen from the defense the
last three weeks the coaching on that
side of the ball steve spagnolo creative
uh willing to do things outside the box
and then the offensive weapons that they
have in kansas city with a special
quarterback and a special play caller
and andy reid and eric b enemy
i'm going to make them the second i
don't feel really really confident about
that but i think right now that's where
they stand for me
right now is the key yeah right now
right right now
it's the tennessee titans right now the
titans are the second best team in the
afc beyond that they are look ryan
tannehill is playing at a level we've
never seen from him before right derek
henry is getting it done in a contract
year the defense is good mike frable's a
great coach right now at this moment the
titans are the team that you don't want
to play in the afc i thought it was the
steelers but you know the difference is
about them mike frable and mike tomlin
are both able to get more out of what
they have rabel has more than what
tomlin has he does and variables got a
lot more right now all due respect than
what tomlin has so i say the titans
right now are the second best team
behind the ravens and the titans could
be that disruptor right they could be
that team that comes in and just really
screws things up in the afc and i kind
of like that i want some chaos and
they've got two of their final three
games against the texans they can still
win the division and if they win those
two games against the texans they will
win the division and uh they're six out
of seven and ryan tannehill has been
great ever since he became the starter
and uh i i do think it's the i really do
i don't know where they're gonna lay
under the power rankings they're gonna
be doing after the show today but the
titans to me are right now the second
best team in the aft i don't think
you're crazy for that they're they're
certainly dangerous and they're uh one
of the hottest teams in football there's
no denying that i guess they're just
when it comes down to it and you give me
a one game situation i just feel a
little bit better about kansas city but
it's it is very close and pittsburgh was
the other team i thought about there as
well uh i mean i thought about buffalo
too
it's tough pickings in the afc in
general where to go right now you know
and then of course new england we all
all have faith that they might get this
straightened out a little bit on the
offensive side of the ball to a degree
you know i think i've seen enough from
new england's offense now to know now
they're not going to ever get it
straightened out this year they might be
a little bit better but it's never going
to be anything special or what we know
to be in new england
next topic the team that needs home
field advantage in the playoffs the most
is well this is a good one and i think
i'm going to go with the green bay
packers if i had to pick one team all
right that's realistically in that
conversation right now like come on i'm
not gonna pick like the philadelphia
eagles or you know something like that
no i'm gonna go with the green bay
packers i think the green bay packers
are
one of the most unimpressive 10-3 teams
i've seen defense not good offense
spotty they got a quarterback that makes
us believe uh and i just don't think
there's any way they can go on the road
to new orleans san francisco and seattle
whatever order it might have might need
to be to win two in a row that they
could do that i think their chances
would greatly uh improve if they were at
home in some bad weather environment
stuff like that where it's 15 degrees
and maybe snow flurries then i go whoa
green bay could be tough to beat up
there that time of the year
i think it's the 49ers because with home
field advantage comes the bye week and
they had the very early buy they need to
have that extra time to get themselves
right to to plan right to have kyle
shanahan the mastermind come up with the
game plan specific to the opponent
they'll be facing in the divisional
round to not have to go to seattle to
not have to go to new orleans that's the
key it isn't about forcing teams to come
to some great home field advantage the
49ers have although it's a lot better
than it used to be when they had all
those traffic problems in santa clara
isn't it funny how the traffic problems
in santa clara go down as the team
improves and performs but that's it
there were never any traffic
that was never the reason was the team
wasn't any good now the team is good and
people show up i think you'd rather get
that extra week off you need that week
off and you don't want to go to new
orleans again you don't want to go to to
seattle and play in a single elimination
setting you want to force those teams to
come to you are you saying a first-round
buy or a home field advantage here
that's what we're talking about home
field advantage what we're saying home
field advantage i'm saying
i mean you're saying for any given game
well i'm just talking about you you know
i could say well then you know they
could be the second seed and not have
home field advantage and have the first
game at home and then they have to go on
the road for one game i don't think
that's that bad you know i think the
question the question may not have been
as specifically written as it could have
or should have been we're both implying
home field advantage throughout the
playoffs right not just in any one game
the one seed i i still think
look i think the 49ers need it the most
because of where they'd have to play and
who they'd have to play if they have to
leave their home stadium because
because i think the the advantage
especially in a playoff atmosphere is
much greater in new orleans and seattle
than it is in san francisco i i i agree
with that but i mean they just proved to
us that they could win in new orleans on
the road not in the playoff game okay
new orleans ain't that dangerous in the
playoffs either they almost lost they
lost once and almost lost twice last
year they could have lost the eagles so
i'm just trying to give you crap and
make you not feel great about your pick
that's all
the blank or the team that's in the
playoffs right now that won't make the
postseason uh
oh
i i mean you know there's nobody right
now i'm riding with the nfc and as i sit
here and look at the afc if i have to
pick one team i'm going to pick the
pittsburgh steelers uh i think there's a
very real chance that they lose to the
buffalo bills this weekend in a tight
close football game there and then you
mentioned the tennessee titans earlier
who are playing really good football uh
that that to me you know it's between
pittsburgh uh and maybe houston there in
that conversation that i would go to but
right now i'll say the pittsburgh
steelers they got you know buffalo this
weekend and who am i missing they still
got one more they still got one more
tough game on the on the schedule they
got baltimore who could be playing for
something who could not be so we'll see
where that goes
even if the ravens aren't playing for
something you play to knock the steelers
out you don't want the steelers you you
and this is a common theme that i come i
come back with every year
if you're a great team in a given year
the last team you want to face in the
playoffs is a team from your division
because that team isn't intimidated by
the fact that you're great this year
because they play you twice a year every
year they're not freaked out by coming
into your stadium they know all the ins
and outs they know the city they know
the routine you do not want a team that
is less uncomfortable coming into your
building and there's no team that's
going to be uh less uncomfortable or
more comfortable whatever the case may
be than somebody from your division i
got i got to mention the vikings in this
category because we've seen this movie
before you know even though kirk cousins
has played well this year and he's been
phenomenal since that meltdown in
chicago that had adam thielen call him
out and then cousins apologized to
feeling boy it feels like it was a long
time ago and it and and and it was from
the standpoint of how cousins has
performed since then but this is his
opportunity to close the deal and the
rams are right there they go to la this
week to play the chargers and you know
the chargers are better than their
record suggests the chargers blew the
jaguars off the field on sunday and and
the vikings we've seen are prone to
stepping in a pothole at the worst
possible time and after the charges
they've got home games back to back
against the packers and the bears
i think they need to run the table to
feel good about their shot and uh we'll
see we'll see but i can see the rams the
way the rams are playing right now i can
see the rams leap frogging the vikings
and stealing the six seed yeah i i hear
you the rams are seemed like they got it
back on track and certainly dangerous
and uh got dallas this week which will
be a tough one but yeah i mean that was
a good question uh you know because the
afc you know houston and tennessee the
way they play each other twice of course
that's just obvious right there with
those two you know pittsburgh and
buffalo playing each other this week and
then of course buffalo's got to play new
england uh so new england will still be
playing for something at that point
that's scary there i mean those three
teams are all in danger of maybe not
making it into the afc playoffs right
now uh so that that's going to be fun to
watch the last three weeks of the season
all right one more yeah blank is the
most dangerous quarterback in the nfc
right now oh blank
is the most dangerous quarterback in the
nfc right now
that's what i said yeah i know that's
what i said i'm talking to myself okay
um i i think i'm still gonna ride with
russell wilson on that conversation i'm
not gonna let like myself be a prisoner
at the moment just because they laid an
egg offensively last week against the
los angeles rams i still think he's a
phenomenal football player he's still
you know in the top three in the mvp
conversation if not still in the top two
and his ability to extend plays his
accuracy with deep balls things like
that i still think he's the most
dangerous guy in the nfc as far as the
relevant relevant teams yes i i
definitely do
oh aaron rodgers chris sims doesn't
believe that you're the most dangerous
quarterback in the nfc right now even
though you've carried your team most of
the years
i just don't please make me the
president of your fan club that's not
that's aaron rodgers i'm telling you i'm
telling you it's aaron rodgers right now
russell wilson is the mvp candidate
jared goff kind of dusted off
some of the memories of 2017 and 2018
but the the one guy i don't want to deal
with now and especially not in the
playoffs is aaron rodgers because he's
been there he's done that he knows how
to make the big throws and the big
moments uh aaron rodgers the most
dangerous quarterback in my mind in the
nfc right now always dangerous yeah i
mean you know you're not going to hear
much don't try it's too it's too late
for you to i'm not going to change it up
i'm going to tell you why why i'm not
going to change too i mean listen you
know i think the world of aaron rodgers
and he's still very very special but i i
guess the thing that makes me put
russell wilson over it is just the
weapons at his disposal are just a
little more dangerous that way that's
really what gave me the tie breaker when
i thought of locket and more and
you know of course dk metcalf and josh
gordon i just that that added to my
answer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports